roy williams saw this genius before
anybody else the north carolina head
coach joining us all the beard looks
good coach it looks good
i told Pauly and Todd that my wife and
grandchildren think I look like Papa
Smurf you look like you're related to
Popovich several people have told me
that pops a great friend I would I would
like it when anybody compares me to pop
all right as a journalist I have to look
over your right shoulder by the way
beautiful home is that the Christmas
tree still up we have a tree that stays
up but it has birds and squirrels okay
we go around our grandchildren make sure
they can say what is what all right well
just as a journalist I wanted to make
sure that if the Christmas tree was up
and the Christmas spirit year-round at
the Williams compound and I'm all for
that but uh thank you coach for joining
us here
what are you takin away from the first
four episodes of the Bulls documentary
oh it's just you know I lived part of
the episodes one and two and then I was
such a huge fan of Michael and loved him
to death and he treats me the same way
now that he did when he was playing at
North Carolina he hasn't changed me at
all but it was brought back great
memories and I heard you talking about
you know maybe force him in the back
court if I'd been a coach to the
Cavaliers they should have just gone to
the locker room
really it was over I got a would there
have been away now looking back let's
say you were gonna devise that you're
the coach of the Cavaliers you're Lenny
Wilkens what would you have done that
could have maybe prevented that shot
well you know everything's better in
hindsight but yeah I would put two guys
on Michael and not allow and try to have
two guys to prevent him from getting the
basketball but you know ever I'm a coach
and so everybody's always got an answer
after it's over with you're standing on
the sidelines and you've got to make
that decision right there everybody knew
that they wanted to get the ball to
Michael and that's the smart thing to do
if you're coaching Michael Jordan you
use him as a decoy I don't know that
that's the smartest thing in the world
unless you've got Scottie Pippen or
somebody else that could make a shot as
well
but yeah I would just put two guys on
and try to stop from getting the ball at
all put me in the huddle in 1982 went
before Michael hits the game-winning
shot against Georgetown who was supposed
to get that shot well it was the most
amazing change of my feelings I've ever
had in my life I thought the entire year
we were gonna win the national
championship I thought we were the best
team I never had any doubts and all of a
sudden with 30 I think it's 31 seconds
to go
coach called the timeout we had the ball
out of bounds on the sideline and to
look on our guys faces as they came to
the bench just shocked me
I said oh my god we could actually lose
this game and that had never been a
thought of mine ever and so Claire sit
down and we as a coaches kneel down in
front of them and coach Smith was the
most magical I've ever known anybody in
my life he said guys we're in great
shape this is exactly where we want to
be if we're going to determine who wins
this game and I'll admit I sort of faked
a call so I could look to the scoreboard
to make sure because door sound was one
up because we scored but Anita kept
going he said guys will run line up to
get it in I don't think they'll be
pressing I think they'll be in a zone
and if they are said let's run to in
James you'll go over for the LOB and
Sam's going to set the screen or Matt's
going to set the screen but if we don't
get the lob which I don't think we will
we'll go week side and if we get the
shot we'll take the shot we'll have the
board covered Sam you get middle
position inside and James you'll have
week side board position so get the
rebound and if they happen to get the
rebound
we will foul but man there's no way in
the world they're going to make a foul
shot in this situation so we'll get
another chance
hmm and all of a sudden everybody just
their whole expression everything look
on everybody's face including mine
change dramatically and as they're going
out I'm standing two feet away from
Coach Smith and he patted Michael on the
10 on the backside and said if you get
the shot knock it in Michael and that
was it so originally yes we wanted to
throw a lob to James Worthy I mean he
had
dominated the game but did we did go
over the weak side and Michael had the
shot and if you look at the tape we had
a great rebound position and all of a
sudden in somebody told Freddie Brown to
throw the ball to Jackie no I know but
that was a talk I've ever heard in my
life and the change of everybody's
expression excuse me Dan
but that skip pass that you had right
that's that wasn't normal back then
right like it is now but but cross-court
against a team like Georgetown that it
surprised me a little bit though no it
was part of the play I still run in the
same play now I mean we try to throw the
LOB and if we don't have it we throw it
on the backside because if you have
somebody like James Worthy going to
cross that's going to trick take the low
forward position that's gonna take him
because he's worried about Jane I don't
have James or Michael we still run this
thing play a little different players
running it when did Michael become the
best player on the team you know James
said two weeks in the episode I'm not
saying I'm not buying that
but because worthy I thought was better
maybe James was National Player of the
Year yeah and the number one pick in the
draft and Michael deferred to them a
great deal as a freshman now as a
sophomore Sam Perkins was still there
and there was no longer deferring at
that time but Michael got better and
better and better we grade the used to
be film that's tape after every game and
that was the firt the Georgetown game
was the only game of the year that
Michael also won the defensive player of
the game Ward and nobody ever remembers
things like that but then his sophomore
year it was over within because he was
the best and continued through that his
junior year I remember Rod Thorn calling
second day of practice after the Bulls
had taken in him and telling Coach Smith
and we were having a staff meeting when
rod called and we were sitting there and
rod said this is a joke we do some
one-on-one stuff and we give him the
ball at between the top of the key in
the center line and regardless of who we
put on me--don't is Roy Williams North
Carolina head coach how do you respond
when people say you know the only person
to stop
Jordan was Dean Smith I just realize how
sad it is if somebody can be that stupid
and you know that's sort of sitting on
the fence with my remark but number one
he did score 20 a game his sophomore
year but - there was no clock people
everybody held the ball on us everybody
ran the clock down I mean there was no
clock but everybody just had ball
control we only had two games that whole
year which scored over 80 points in a
game because every game we were chasing
people kind of thing but Michael Jordan
counters it best by saying hey coach
Dean Smith gave me all the fundamentals
that allowed me to do everything later
on and I think that's Michael's
greatness it's just a great thing in the
episode the other night he said I didn't
particularly care for Phil Jackson
coming in Doug Collins wanted to give me
the ball and Phil wanted to take it out
of my hands but you saw where the
timeout Phil says pax is the guy it's
open because Michael Jordan only cared
about one thing women that's all it made
a difference to him you also look at two
of the greatest players of all time
Larry Bird was homesick at Indiana
Michael got to North Carolina and he was
homesick did he almost leave no no no no
no not at all he loved it now everybody
misses your mama's home cooking every
player I've ever had was a little
homesick but no that was anybody would
say that is a no that's just somebody
saying something but there was no doubt
that that young man loved it there from
the first day he stepped on campus
especially when the pickup game started
and in the basketball practice started
he was an incredible person incredible
player but you also good
you had Ewing when you know Michael when
Ewing shows up does Michael then play
one-on-one with him yeah at North
Carolina that was one of my great
stories because they were there the same
weekend pretty good two prospects on
campus that were pretty good but so I'm
taking him over to the football game and
so we dismissed meeting with I mean
Carmichael where we played at that time
and so we go down on the court to walk
out the back door to go to the
football game and the basketballs there
and and Michael says we got a couple
minutes I see yeah so he starts messing
with Patrick in back you know backing
him down and then faking him shooting
and he's just laughing at Patrick
Patrick's going 25% and I mean maybe not
in that they had street clothes on and
so at one point at Rick had had enough
and he got the ball and he backed
Michael down one dribble two dribbles
and then turned and got bumped it on his
head he Michael said you ready to go
coach the football game there's so many
good things Act look I go back I told
you that story well I don't have to tell
you the story but I was at the Jimmy V
golf tournament and Michael would get
competitive at an auction item and he he
bought the motorcycle for you and he
didn't Mike didn't want the motorcycle
he wanted to win the motorcycle and then
gave it to you we actually bought it to
in the auction gave it to my wife
yeah and I said Michael we were talking
about a different way to go to the
grocery store at the beach and they
bring the motorcycle in and wanna say I
can you can buy that for me and I can
take that and Michael said you ride him
and she said I said Michael she's never
ridden a bike in her life and Wanda said
I could learn and Michael says I'm gonna
buy that for you and wicked one assist
no I mean it petrified us and but he
bought the motorcycle why are you doing
this he said do you realize how many
shrimp fried shrimp dinner she's fixed
me over the years that's great and we
still have the motorcycle and we just we
went to see about getting license and
bought helmets but she slipped in the
parking lot at kayuu and broke her
collarbone and then packed croci the
owner of the seventies was ran into us
says please that's after he had had his
crash that he almost was killed it don't
do that so we still have the motorcycle
and wicked Wanda who is only knows how
to get on the zoom call he's originally
going to make it into a the back side of
a coffee table because how do you get
rid of a motorcycle Michael
but he loved her fried shrimp that's
great the whole g-league phenomenon here
coach
is this bad for college basketball that
these kids are deciding that instead of
going for one and done they're gonna go
into the G League you know I don't think
it's it's bad for college basketball but
the NBA is going to make their rules for
what they want they're you know they're
not our partner they're gonna make the
rules is what they think is best for the
NBA the there'll be several players
every year that would try to do that and
that's okay if they have no interest in
college the only negative thing I think
is that they're calling kids now who
have already signed and committed to go
to college and trying to see if they
have any interests I don't think they
should be doing that much that's my own
personal opinion but some kids really
don't want to go to college and that's
okay you know there's going to be a game
twice a year where one team has on a
Duke uniform and the other team has on
the North Carolina uniform and they're
still going to play and it's going to be
that way next year in ten years and
here's from now but the NBA they're
doing the right thing in the most part
because they're doing what they think is
best for their game do you think we're
gonna eventually get back to coming out
of high school if you want to go I think
they will you know and Kobe made the
right decision LeBaron Garnett though
all those guys made the right to see
there's a lot of guys that made a bad
decision and I've said it all along
there's no great rule for that there's
no perfect rule for everybody there's
kids that think they're NBA players and
all of a sudden two years later the out
of the game and have no education and
you know are not really equipped to go
out in the world but there's no perfect
rule but I think we'll eventually get
back to that yes did you recruit Kobe
made one phone call to his father and
had the conversation and I was at Kansas
at that time and I felt like when I got
off the phone call I'm glad I had a
chance to talk to his dad but that young
man is going to the NBA
what about Garnett I'd never called him
but I saw him in high school and knew he
was going the NBA and LeBron you didn't
even place the goal no no you knew
anybody else that you just said
worth it oh there's been a few yeah
those are the big ones and some guys
that I thought were going to go straight
to the league at when we had that rule
didn't do it and then guys like Zion
Williams and I think he loved his
college experience Tyler Hansbrough
played for us for years and loved
everything about it but it's it's again
no perfect rule for everybody but you
had a chance did you think you were
getting Zion boy I worked off and we
left his home on the last night I'll
have to admit that he were Davis my
assistant and myself we really thought
this could really work out it was it was
hard for me to get in the car because
when I left the porch I was walking on
air but the level to get in the car and
all then all of a sudden you find out
he's going to Duke yeah it was it was it
was not a good night the announcement
was made but you know and then we had
somebody get in the equipment room and
you can snip a few the stitches on the
shoes and I just saw something that Luke
combs who's a country singer said that
he had a bed and he's from North
Carolina see it had a bet with his
guitar guy and his band he took Duke and
Luke combs took North Carolina and he's
on the air we don't want to start that
rumor attach it to your coach we you you
and you and Coach K get along are you
competitive with him yes on the
basketball court there's no question in
recruiting but we believe in almost all
the things the same and you know we were
served on the board of directors in ABC
for a long time together we both value
the right things and at least they
seemed to be right to us you know that
kind of thing
but you know he doesn't play golf so
that's the other place that I compete
Moomins yeah I wonder how he'd be as a
golfer I have no idea I don't think I've
ever seen him play I think he'd be too
intense so coach well I don't you know I
don't know he's played tennis
and at one time I think he really
enjoyed tennis but Mike has done just a
great job and you know when Zion went
there I wished him good luck and but
yeah the the story about the stitches
big company yeah
not from you thank you for that one Luke
roams the country singer who has done a
great job my best to your wife and thank
you again for sharing the stories that
I'm sure you're probably quite tired of
telling the same stories over and over
but you do it with such great enthusiasm
and keep the beard looks great
well I love those stories it was part of
my life and I'm glad that I said earlier
that Paulie and Todd are so reverent to
you during their program they never
disagree Thank You coach